let's go new blitz game yeah i i saw the
jonathan tron's video
it's been pointing out some great
content beating stockfish
there's a game carlson lost against
nagmansen
all right let's play
i'll play this opening bishop c5 tricky
line
if d3 i'll play lukini let's go lukini
time
i should really study the leukemia a bit
deeper
oh what is this i haven't studied this
line
so i assume the knight g5
this is new for me
i mean the idea is queen h5 and then win
everything
i'm wondering if i can play queen f6
queen h5 g6 takes and then rook h8
which i think traps the queen in the end
i mean h7 is still hanging after takes
but then i play this
let's do it rather white be the one
thinking even though i spent a long
long time on that move yeah so takes
rookie chase
there's this move but then queen g7 and
still rook h8
wait what
i'm either missing something or i'm not
missing something
and it's winning after eight moves
pretty sure it's winning i mean i saw
this when i played uh
queen f6
okay i i won i won a queen
after eight moves in lukini opening
success
discovered a new a new kind of trap i
guess
um
i play f4 threatening this
i'm allowing this because in the end
i'll have this in this
let's go 14 move win in lukini
haven't played too many leukines that
was nice
yeah this is a move i had not studied
prior
but probably probably not the most
challenging move can study it though
it takes takes i mean the opponent was
clearly trying to punish me
and then it completely backfired
after g6 it's already like troublesome
for whites um because this lost a queen
and if this this would have been
interesting but this is also bad because
queen g7
and the knight gets stuck the queen has
to move somewhere
and even if queen h6 i can take
and then rook hate and i have six i i'm
still winning a piece
anyway i hope that inspires some people
to maybe look into the leukini
if this goes on youtube hope you enjoyed
that
follow on twitch and subscribe